okay we begin here you know you probably
haven't
heard the name brittany hill and if you
have you certainly haven't heard it as
often or as loudly or accompanied with
as much performative grief
as a name like george floyd or michael
brown but
the video of her death at the hands of
chicago gang members a video which came
to my attention this weekend
though it's been online for over a year
is
impossible to get out of your head once
you've seen it um
the footage captured by a police
surveillance camera
i'll just describe it to you it shows
hill
uh standing near her car talking to two
men she's holding her one-year-old
daughter in her arms
when the car with her killers rolls up
slowly hill's daughter actually
innocently smiles and waves to the men
inside of course not knowing what's
about to happen
moments later they open fire the two men
standing with hill take off in opposite
directions
the men in the car stop get out continue
shooting
hill at some point is struck in the
abdomen she takes cover behind a parked
vehicle and lays on top of her daughter
shielding her daughter from the gunfire
the killers drive away 20 seconds later
one of the men who had been standing
with hill runs back into the frame
apparently holding a firearm
gets into his car and drives away with
hill still lying bleeding on the
pavement
20 seconds after that the other man
returns with someone else
and the two place hill in the back seat
of their car presumably to
bring her to the hospital and the
one-year-old girl stands up
watches as her mother is carried off um
an older man then comes and picks up the
child and takes her away
now i had originally planned to play the
video
of this crime on the show but i've
decided not to do that
you can go to my twitter and watch it if
you want to
i don't want to force you to watch it
i'm not going to just put it into the
middle of this
show and uh and it it's seared into my
brain now and probably not for the
better um
i don't want to do that to you but if
you want to see it you can
now the alleged perpetrators
of this as the judge correctly called it
chilling mind-boggling and utterly
senseless crime
were arrested and charged with
first-degree murder a short time later
police say the shooting was probably
some kind of gang retaliation
though they don't believe that hill was
the intended target
maybe it was the men standing with with
hill i guess we can assume
this all happened over a year ago now
when it happened it made some waves
locally in the immediate aftermath but
it was quickly forgotten
even on the local level it seems most
people across the country never
heard of it even after the dramatic and
gut-wrenching footage leaked to the
public it leaked to the public a year
ago
there were no mass protests there were
no memorial services attended by
politicians from across the country
no public officials weeping
uncontrollably over her casket as the
mayor of minneapolis did for george
floyd
and her casket speaking of which we can
assume was not plated in gold like
george floyd's was
nor is her face like george floyd's
featured on murals all over the nation
no major corporations expressed their
sorrow over her death
the democratic party didn't kneel in
silence to honor her
nobody rioted nobody looted black lives
matter didn't organize any
demonstrations on her behalf
no liberal activists or politicians told
us to
quote remember her name no laws were
passed in response to her death
no calls for reform no famous athlete
said anything about her colin kaepernick
didn't say anything
nothing she just died and that was it
another statistic another tally to add
to the body count
and as far as the body count goes hill's
death uh last year followed a memorial
day weekend in chicago that saw 38
shootings and five deaths
over the weekend she was one of 490
murders in the city that year
there have been over 420 homicides
already in 2020 in chicago a year that
has seen
the most violent day in chicago in over
half a century 18 homicides
on one sunday in may but none of these
murders
or any of the hundreds of other murders
that happen in our cities every year
provoke outrage or garner attention even
remotely on par with the killings of
george floyd michael brown freddie gray
etc now the point i'm making here
has of course been made many times by
many people and for good reason
it's an important point but those who
seek to justify this disparity in
coverage and outrage
and attention have a number of responses
at the ready so i want to address
the two most common rejoinders to this
argument that i'm making right now the
point that i make
number one they'll say well in cases
like britney hill the murderers are
are arrested and brought to justice so
there's no need to protest
it's true that in this specific case of
britney hill the murderers were arrested
and charged thanks in large part to the
fact that they happen to commit their
crime in full view of a surveillance
camera
but a great many murders in chicago and
elsewhere go unsolved and unprosecuted
every year
besides george floyd's killer was also
arrested and brought to justice
um that you may have noticed has done
nothing whatsoever to quell the protests
the killing of michael brown was
investigated on both the local and
federal level and both investigations to
include the investigation conducted
by obama's doj cleared the officer of
wrongdoing
citing among other things eyewitness
testimony
and forensic evidence proving that
michael brown was shot while in the
process of attacking the officer and
trying to kill him trying to disarm him
this was proven but this also
did nothing to satiate the protesters
still to this day they repeat the
thoroughly and repeatedly debunked lie
that brown had his hands up and was
pleading for his life
you hear this even from the protesters
the george floyd pro
they still repeat this hands up don't
shoot thing
the actual outcome of these cases seems
to matter very little or not at all to
the protesters so that excuse doesn't
work
the second excuse you hear is uh well
the the protesters are speaking out
against
injustice in government they're they're
seeking certain legal and policy changes
and citizen on citizen murder is not a
matter of governmental injustice and
there's no need to call for changes to
law or policy in response to it
as the argument goes now as covered
above the problem with this
response is that the protesters are
often upset about things that do not
amount to governmental injustice michael
brown was not a matter of governmental
injustice
the vast majority of police shootings
are not unjust even the majority of
police shootings
of unarmed suspects are not unjust as i
have
previously showed we talked about it on
the show last week
but even if this is about injustice or
perceived injustice
that would be all the more reason to
take this to take to the street for the
sake of the brittany hills of the world
these crime-plagued cities have been
brought to their knees
by decades of ineffectual and unjust
democratic policy
the the epidemic of violent crime in
places like chicago
is most certainly the result at least in
part
of bad laws and bad leaders who for a
start
have facilitated the collapse of the
nuclear family by cynically breeding
dependence
on welfare and other nanny state
programs
also many of the killers who terrorize
these communities
have already been convicted of multiple
violent felonies
and yet they're still on the street they
are filtered again and again through the
court system and prison system and then
back into the community until they
finally do something
so incomprehensibly heinous that there's
no choice but to send them away for good
it was the case we talked about last
week three friends in florida
were executed in cold blood by a man who
had over
200 felonies 15 convictions and
two stints in state prison already under
his belt
this was a man who long ago announced
that he is uninterested in becoming
and being a productive member of
civilized society he
but he had to write that message in the
blood of three dead men
for the courts to finally take him at
his word injustice
yes there is quite a lot of injustice
fueling the chaos and bloodshed in our
streets
the excuses don't hold up you know a
movement that that was really concerned
with the unjust killing of innocent
lives
would be eager to stand up for brittany
hill to speak up
on her behalf to say her name and
certainly a movement that claims to
defend the dignity and value of human
life
would have quite a lot to say about
brittany hill and the many hundreds of
victims like her each year
because for all the grief i give blm the
fact is that
life matters is a message that our
culture desperately needs to hear i
agree with that
it's a message that if it was listened
to and heated
would save many lives would probably
have saved brittany hill's life
it's just a shame that the movement
which claims to defend life
black life specifically seems in
practice to care very little for it
and that's the issue you know
it's it's it's very clear that in many
of these communities
you have people like the killers of
britney hill
they weren't even they as i said they
weren't even targeting her
they were going after someone else the
fact that she was standing there
and was holding her her child meant
nothing to them
they didn't care her to them her life
literally meant nothing there's almost
something
there's um it's it's in a way it's
almost more chilling that she wasn't
being targeted because
because of the indifference in it okay a
crime
motivated by hatred someone going to
kill someone
uh you know a jilted lover or something
killing someone
it's a it's a horrible thing terrible
but you kind of that's something that
you can
comprehend you can contextualize that
okay someone killing out of hate and
anger and jealousy
all right people have all people have
been doing that since time immemorial
but when you find these kinds of
killings like you do so often especially
in the cities in these communities
crimes of just indifference now i don't
i don't hate you nothing against you i
just your your life just means nothing
to me i don't care
the life of your child that you're
holding means nothing to me
i feel like killing these other two guys
for some
pointless beef and you're in the way so
i'm just gonna shoot you too
whatever
though that that crime is motivated
by a total indifference to human life
so life matters yes it black life
matters
all life matters that is an important
message
those killers tell them that
where the message needs to be but
these are exactly the cases that blm
antifa the left
ignores thank you for tuning in to the
daily wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content